finally
441 days after the cdc implemented a
federal mass mandate for public
transportation
a federal judge has struck down the
stupid rule which was set to expire
yesterday before the bureaucrats decided
to extend it for another two weeks two
weeks where have we heard that one
before district court judge catherine
kimball mizell
ruled that the extended mandate quote
exceeded the cdc's statutory authority
improperly invoked the good cause
exception to notice and comment
rulemaking and failed to adequately
explain its decisions i actually got a
text from a friend of mine
when this came out he was 30 000 feet
traveling on a flight and he said wow
you're not going to believe it the
captain just came over the loudspeaker
and said that the mask rule is no longer
in effect and almost everyone took their
masks off other people got videos of
this happening on flights around the
country take a listen
the bible administration announced that
the transportation security
administration will no longer enforce
the federal mandate
requiring mass in all u.s airports and
onboard aircraft
[Applause]
finally effective immediately
immediately mass are optional for all
airport employees crew members and
customers inside us airports and on
board aircraft effective immediately and
everybody is very very excited about
this because this judge found that the
good clause exception did not hold here
the good clause exception is a provision
of the administrative procedures act
that allows d.c bureaucrats to break the
rules for rulemaking when compliance
would be quote impracticable unnecessary
or contrary to the public interest so if
an emergency required an agency to act
with haste
it would be permitted to cut corners
but we're more than a year and a half
into this nonsense if there ever was an
emergency that permitted this kind of
power grab we are certainly long past it
this is great news as you can see the
people are so excited there in that
video on the flight i've got a flight on
thursday to boston i'm giving a speech
at boston university i look forward to
testing the rule perhaps i can become
the rosa parks of airplane muzzles
but
the ruling is bittersweet if all those
people on that airplane were so happy to
take the mask off
as we know that they are as we know that
we all were when we were flying around
and taking public transportation
why didn't we just all do it why did it
take 441 days it is a bittersweet moment
because it shows us just how far our
country has fallen it shows us just how
much the ruling class our crooked ruling
class is taken from us
we are 109 weeks into two weeks to slow
the spread and we're celebrating that
our rulers might now finally allow us to
breathe again
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from vita tipple
who says michael i'm getting worried for
you
your show was so hard-hitting and so on
the money that you're likely to make
some very powerful people very cross i
hope you've got a good security team
around you thank you very much for your
concern we do have good security here at
the daily wire and most importantly
i haven't been revealing too much
information on the clintons so i think
my health is secure i i've been going
after a lot of the crooks here in our in
our country and in our world not just
biden
but the corporate leaders not just the
corporate leaders but the institutional
investors
we were going yesterday after blackrock
after state street some of those big
investors that are pressuring the corp
the regular corporations to become
corporations with regard to twitter with
regard to all of these other political
issues but as long as i don't go too
hard after bill and hillary i i hope
that i will not be suicided any time
soon i i think that i can sleep easy one
of the reasons i can sleep easy my
bowling branch sheets right now go to
bolinbranch.com
use promo code michael put simply bowlin
branch are the greatest sheets i've ever
used period that's it end of discussion
they use the best 100 organic cotton
threads on earth for a superior softness
and better night's sleep the sheets are
not just buttery breathable and
impossibly soft to start they get softer
with every single wash they got me
hooked these guys they're like a drug
dealer hanging around a bad neighborhood
they gave me a little bit to try back
when bowling branch first came on the
show and now i'm hook i'm a sucker they
got me i'm buying sheets left and right
i'm buying them for family members i'm
buying them for me they're just amazing
and fortunately because their prices are
so reasonable you can sleep like you're
at a five-star hotel every single night
for not a lot of money did you miss the
bowling branch april sale well our
listeners get exclusive access to a
post-sale 20 site-wide discount through
the end of april with promo code michael
go to bowlingbranch.com
that's b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code michael for 20
off through the end of april
i don't want to be a debbie downer guys
i'm really excited i am i'm i hate those
stupid masks every time the stewardess
walks away on the flight i take the dumb
mask down
i've i'll i've been cheating at these
things from the beginning i don't wear
the masks in the airport but sometimes
they'll get you they'll say you can't
sir you will not be allowed to board the
flight if you don't put your stupid mask
on and then they've got you either you
cancel the trip
or you put the dumb mask on
and
in not all but in most cases i felt it's
worth doing the trip speaking at some
liberal place
speaking and talking about how dumb the
masks are i felt that was worth the cost
but
is this really what we've come to
i would bet 97
of people who take airplanes
wanted to lose the dumb masks
over a year ago
and we all just kind of went along with
it i would bet you 90
of stewards and stewardesses
except for the insane power trippers who
love the masks but probably 90 of them
hate the dumb masks there was one
stewardess i saw a few months ago who
was wearing a mesh face mask i thought
it was great
i bet you 100 of the captains don't want
to wear the dumb masks and they probably
don't up in the cockpit
and yet
we all just went along with it like
little sheep
even though we knew it was preposterous
as a medical matter we knew it was
completely ridiculous almost from the
beginning and as a political matter it
was absurd as well
and yet we went along with it and now it
takes one judge i love this judge she's
a phenomenal she's a trump appointee she
was put on the bench just a couple of
years ago she's 35 years old so she's
got a long career ahead of her we hope
and
so i'm glad
but what this is this is what we've come
to an america as we are our basic
freedoms our basic way of life the
ability to breathe freely
is now contingent on the whims of a
judge
that's not a great situation to be in
it's a good start i don't want a clutch
defeat from the jaws of victory i'll
take the win when i can get it but we
have a long
way
to go
news report out today
just to show you this is completely
unrelated to the masks but it shows you
the the depth and severity of the
political problem in the united states
you know florida passed this this
parental rights and education law which
prohibits weird
uh sex education in elementary schools
florida just in general has gotten a
little bit tougher on keeping the
radical leftist ideology out of the
classroom getting back to the abcs not
the lgbs or the crts and so as a result
of this
florida has here's the npr headline
florida has rejected 54 math books from
the classroom because they say critical
race theory
appeared in some of those books
this is 54 math textbooks in k through
12
classrooms that is a 41
that's 41
of the 132 books that were submitted for
review to the florida department of
education and the libs are reacting to
this they're saying
this just proves how crazy the florida
conservatives are they're banning books
they're look at how
what an overreach this is in florida
that's not my reaction
my reaction to this is
wow what the hell were they teaching in
those classrooms
what 54 books 41
of the books in math class we're not
talking about history or civics or
literature math 41 of the books
were teaching critical race theory and
similar sorts of concepts
i'm not even i'm not even really
surprised when i reflect on it yesterday
we read a math assignment from
pennsylvania that was given out in 2017.
so five years ago now
in which to get the right answer to the
math question you had to know facts
about the radical leftist author maya
angelou's life so really very little
surprises me these days but when i see
this florida band's 54 math textbooks
you know what that says to me that says
it's a good start
good start there's probably a long way
to go though
because i bet there are a lot of books
being taught in history
in civics they probably don't even have
civics anymore in english
in
possibly in the hard sciences
that are
radical and leftist and they need to be
booted out of the classroom
and there's nothing anti-american about
that or illiberal or contrary to
education or whatever
a seventh grade classroom is not a
thriving free marketplace of ideas where
new scientific discoveries are going to
be found there's no broad academic
freedom in middle school or high school
for that matter
parents have a right the political
community has a right to have a say
in what its children are being taught
because the purpose of k-12 education is
to form good citizens the purpose of
k-12 education is to educate and give
people a good solid foundation so that
they can go and continue their studies
and their vocational training and go on
and become good upstanding citizens and
when you teach kids that america is evil
and white people are evil and boys are
really girls when you teach them that
you're harming their education
there is a long way to go i i strongly
suspect there are a whole lot more books
we need to ban from the classroom
because those books are not educating
students they are poisoning students
minds and poisoning our country and if
kids want to read them they can read
them on their own time but they're not
going to read them in taxpayer-funded
classrooms
the libs always go back to this this
contradictory argument they say these
books are not being taught these ideas
are not being taught in k-12 and it's
really important that they are and thank
goodness for
my favorite twitter account libs of tik
tok certainly in my top five favorite
twitter accounts thank goodness for them
because libs of tiktok is exposing
the
the
corruption that we're seeing
in the schools the these
kooky school teachers
at the same time that the left-wing
politicians are saying this stuff isn't
being taught you crazy conservatives are
tilting at windmills at the same time
that the liberal politicians are making
that argument the kooky teachers are
going on to tick-tock and saying yeah i
real i do want to trans my
five-year-olds but unfortunately the
parents in florida aren't letting me do
it
it's there this is really elemental
stuff okay
boys are different than girls right is
different from wrong death is different
than life when we want to inculcate a
culture of life we got to check out 40
days for life abortion is one of those
issues that is always kind of in the
news and it's about to be a whole lot
more in the news because the supreme
court might overrule roe versus way
there's a very strong chance that they
will you need to know the arguments okay
the arguments are all on the pro-life
side
the scientific arguments the ethical
arguments it's funny that the libs which
always say they want to follow the
science
do not follow the science on one of the
most important issues which is abortion
you need the best arguments you can get
which is why you've got to go check out
the wonderful book from 40 days for life
the number two amazon christian
bestseller what to say when the complete
new guide to discussing abortion how to
change minds and convert hearts in a
brave new world 40 days for life is
based in texas it's one of the largest
pro-life grassroots organizations in the
country they got a million volunteers in
1 000 cities holding peaceful 40-day
vigils outside of abortion facilities to
save lives and help abortion workers to
leave their jobs get that book what to
say when today covers the old arguments
the new arguments everything in between
go get it at 40daysforlife.com
to help end abortion
wherever you live
thanks to our friends at libs of tick
tock
we know that a middle school teacher
in florida
is very very furious because
uh in florida it is increasingly
frowned upon
to try to trans little kids
my state decided that it was a good idea
to ban the use of the word gay in the
classroom educators can now not are not
allowed to say gay in the classroom
anymore
this is a life or death issue
why do i say that
one of the most important
statistics that i use in my curriculum
when teaching anti-oppression
specifically about lgbtqia issues is 72
percent you decrease the likelihood of a
young trans person of wanting to commit
suicide if all you do is use the proper
pronouns
for that person
72 percent
you can save a life by using one
often two-letter word
for a person
misgendering someone can have them go on
a spiral where they don't want to live
anymore
and now we're not allowed to say gay
even if we are gay
even if we have
an openly same sex relationship
even if we are openly non-binary or
trans as per as educators we cannot talk
about who we are we exist
i've got one really important statistic
for you to know when you are watching
libs on tick tock and that statistic is
420
420 percent of the statistics that libs
on tick tock cite are completely made up
420
you can reduce your risk of losing iq
points 420 percent by not watching libs
on tick tock i obviously don't believe
this statistic this woman is citing that
72 you're
if you don't call boys she and girls he
then you are going to encourage them to
commit suicide and if only you call them
by the wrong pronoun then you'll
decrease their suicide
suicidality by 70 plus percent i just
don't believe that and one of the
reasons i don't believe that is because
uh this woman is saying a whole lot of
things in this video that i know for a
fact are not true
like you're not allowed to say gay in
classrooms in florida that's just not
true that just isn't true at all that's
completely made up it's nowhere in the
florida education bill and it's just not
the case the the woman is
saying that she is non-binary well
that's not true because that's not
possible that's not that's not a real
thing so she isn't that so she's she's
wrong she i'm not saying she's a liar
but she's certainly mistaken she says
that she teaches anti-oppression in the
classroom
where does that fit in in the in the
school day schedule is that so for you
have homeroom in the morning
then you've got social studies maybe
then math class then anti-oppression and
then
english language and arts is that and in
literature is that what you've got i
don't know where is anti-oppression no
this woman is a radical political
activist
who is using
taxpayer dollars in florida
i think that's the state that she's in
right yeah she's using taxpayer dollars
to indoctrinate little kids into her
radical weird leftist ideologies she
says i'm not even allowed to be open
about my same-sex relationships in the
classroom you certainly shouldn't be
yeah i don't i don't want you teaching
that in the classroom that's weird don't
talk about your sex life in the
classroom
period no i don't think you should be
talking about your sex life in any grade
but certainly not in k-3 or pre-k until
third grade certainly not
if only
you
use the
wrong pronouns then you will save a life
even if it were true i know it's not
true
but even if it were true it would still
be wrong this kind of emotional
blackmail is the way to madness
because it actually
this is
kind of a strange connection and it ties
in with another creepy weird sex thing
but when i was at yale with senator cruz
last week we were asked a question by
this kid who obviously just wanted to
get some headlines and tell a joke he
said if it would end world hunger would
you
perform a certain sex act on another man
and it was funny and people laughed in
the room
but it's actually not a complicated
question the answer is no
i wouldn't do that
no it wouldn't end world hunger no
calling kids the wrong pronoun isn't
going to reduce their suicidality or
depression or anxiety it's probably
going to increase it by hardening their
gender dysphoria
but
no i wouldn't do that because that's
called consequentialism
that's that's
that's called the ends justify the means
that is a morally idiotic way of viewing
the world that's called it takes a few
a few broken eggs to make an omelet
that logic that by committing an
intrinsically disordered evil action
you might achieve some good end that has
been used to justify the worst crimes in
history and it's morally incoherent and
it doesn't lead to good outcomes
anyway
this kind of stuff
is what's being taught
all over the place and it's not even
just in
san francisco or l.a or new york florida
is a pretty red state
and this kind of stuff is being taught
in even redder states i was in kansas i
was in kansas to give a talk at washburn
university just a few weeks ago
last i checked kansas is pretty
conservative
not exactly
san francisco or chicago and before i
gave my talk the president of that
university jerry farley
condemned me
he personally signed the contract
inviting me to come speak
i was invited to speak on how boys and
girls are different
and he condemned me he said my views
were terrible
this president of a public university
said that the statement that boys and
girls are different is terrible horrible
we think this is awful i'm tara i'm
sorry the guy's invited
and i didn't back down and i went and i
spoke anyway
and it was a totally packed out house
i invited the president of the
university jerry farley to come he could
share the stage with me he could present
his alternative thesis
to my very controversial one the boys
and girls are different we could debate
it we could have a civil and open
exchange i didn't hear back from
president farley he was much too
cowardly to actually stand by his
calumny against me and his defamation
and so he just hit up in his ivory tower
and i went there and i gave a speech
about what a jerk that guy is and why my
views are right felt it was respectful
but forceful and then
just saw this news story yesterday and
i'm nuts
i'm not saying i did this i'm not
totally taking credit for it but i'm not
i'm not here well here's the headline
washburn president jerry farley
to retire
i like that washburn university
announced monday afternoon during a news
conference that farley will retire on
september 30th of this year
there he is
is it because probably the worst scandal
of jerry farley's career occurred just a
few weeks ago because of little old me
is it because jerry farley a man who who
dines on the taxpayer dollar who
runs an educational institution doesn't
know the difference between boys and
girls and actually condemns people who
says that there are basic distinctions
in biology and human nature might it
have something to do with that that he
would smear not just me i'm a big boy
with thick skin but smear half of this
half of the country and a huge portion
of students of his university who are
conservative
as hateful
misinformers bigots that sort of thing
is it because he smeared what i would
suspect is the vast majority of parents
paying tuition who know that boys and
girls are different that he smeared them
as hateful and bigoted and spreading
misinformation i don't know
but one thing i will tell you is i'm
really happy that he is stepping down he
is not fit to be the president of
university a a man who behaves in that
way
a man who's that confused
sexually intellectually morally whatever
that man has no business running a
university
and frankly it's scandalous that he ran
it this long if that's the kind of
cowardice and intellectual decay that he
is demonstrating we need to see a lot
more of that we see that florida law or
the consequence of various florida laws
to say 54 math textbooks have been
kicked out of the classroom for being
too radical yeah that's a good start
jerry farley stepping down he's not the
only one and he's not even close to the
worst of the offenders at these
universities he's he's being booted out
of the school or he's stepping down or
however it's happening i don't really
care i'm just glad it's happening that's
a good start
that's a good start when i spoke a few
years ago
at
a university of missouri kansas city
actually was not far from washburn
university
and
the chancellor of that university uh
chancellor agrawal also after i was
physically attacked there he came out
and he smeared me and it was the same
sort of thing he said that this is not
in accord with our values here we don't
believe that men and women are different
that guy should be gone too it's a
scandal that he still holds that job
it
a lot of these guys we have to get
tougher
the modern conservative movement was
launched with a book called
god and man at yale subtitled the
superstitions of academic freedom and
the point of the book was that academic
freedom is a total lib psyop it's not
real it has no
it has it has meaning in as much as
scholars are free to pursue their own
interests in their studies but it
doesn't mean that wackos are free to
teach whatever nonsense they want in a
classroom that is never what academic
freedom was supposed to mean in even
when it did sort of make sense
you don't have the right to do that and
the point of that book was basically
that we need to fire bad teachers we
need to fire radicals in buckley's idea
radical atheists and radical socialists
in the classroom in university
classrooms much less
k through 12.
got to do that
folks there there are some true
radicals on campus at the university
level there is a professor
at the university of new hampshire
who is coming out and saying that it is
ineffective
to call all
sexual relationships between children
and adults
predatory
speaking of predators we got to be
careful we got to protect what's ours
and you need a will which is why you got
to check out epic will right now go to
epicwill.com
use promo code
knowles i frankly i just went back and
redid my will
myself
epic will they got me thinking
i got a little baby i got to do the
responsible thing it's very important
that someday we're all going to go when
i go
that
the assets that i have are
spent in the way that i want them to be
in a way that i think is good that my
loved ones are going to be taken care of
okay if you do not have a will in place
you have no say in the future of your
children let that sink in
your kids your most precious asset if
you have not made a will yet you're not
alone but we're gonna make it super easy
for you go to epicwill.com
when you use promo code knowles you will
get a wonderful incredible package
starting at just 119
when you use promo code knowles you will
save 10
it's super duper easy so right now go to
epicwill.com
[Music]
this is the most important five minutes
that you are going to spend all day
you know sports are not supposed to be
the place
for radical aggressive political
speeches and virtue signaling so nba
star jonathan isaac is one of the few
professionals that knows that fact very
well isaac faced heavy criticism from
the media for not buying into the
political theater over the past few
years and he still stood strong
that's why i'm super duper excited to
announce that jonathan is writing a book
with the daily wire called why i stand
jonathan's book will be about the rise
of his basketball career his journey
into faith and his strength to stand
alone in the face of immense pressure
the book is available for pre-order
right now on amazon reserve your copy
today also we've got a great new
short series that we're we're going to
be releasing somewhat regularly
i was out giving a speech at washburn
university there was a protest organized
against me and so my producer decided to
just walk outside with a camera and get
some video and see what was going on and
then my producer actually invited the
the girl who organized the protest
against me
to come cross her on picket line sit
down watch my speech and then she and i
sat and spoke to one another for
probably
i don't know 15 or 20 minutes after the
speech go check it out it's on my
youtube channel right now the michael
knowles youtube channel we'll be right
back with a lot more
there's a professor at the university of
new hampshire who is
quite insistent
that we should not call all adult child
sexual relationships
predatory this would be professor david
finkelhor
he is the director of the crimes against
children research center he was giving a
virtual talk called sex crimes against
juveniles involving elements of
voluntary participation
implications for prevention and response
without further ado take it away
professor groomer
also if young people are initiating
sexual activities with adults
or enthusiastically involved we can't be
effective in working with them
if we assume that all such relationships
start with a predatory or criminally
inclined inclined adult
the
as we see in the discussion young people
bridle
at being forced into this
box of being seen as being the victim of
a predator
and so there are
reasons for learning
about what the dynamics are and and how
to talk about them so that we can
better help the young people who are in
these situations
just to clarify here
this professor is not talking about a
relationship between i don't know
a 16 year old and a
20 year old
we're not talking about a relationship
where
uh maybe it maybe
or maybe not it violates the law but
maybe you know you can tell they're sort
of within an age range that seems
somewhat reasonable they both could have
been in college at the same time they
both could have been in high school at
the same time sometimes these types of
relationships are covered by what's
called romeo and juliet laws that's not
what this guy's talking about this guy's
talking about relationships
between kids little kids
and
old adults
we're not talking about 16 and 19 we're
talking about like 12 and and 40.
okay we're talking about
the whole spectrum here of child or
younger than 12.
and adult maybe older than 40 sexual
relationships and his claim is
well
we shouldn't begin with the premise that
all of these relationships begin with a
predatory adult
no i think we can i'm pretty sure we can
begin with that assumption i think that
is always the case
i don't think there's any exception to
that at all
and
i think that this kind of logic is
illogic is
really creepy and dangerous but it's
i don't even just mean to beat up on
this professor he's frankly a symptom of
a much larger social and philosophical
problem
we're all focused on
the will
on the ch what the child wants the
child's desire
traditionally in this country
we have age of consent laws we have age
of consent laws because we believe that
kids cannot give
mature informed consent on a whole host
of issues
this is why you're not allowed to get a
tattoo until you're 18.
this is why
you're there are limits to sexual
activity that you can engage in until
you are a certain age
this is why
little kids have to do what mommy and
daddy tell them to do
because they're not old enough to give
consent
now
as
conservatives have said for years you're
going to see these laws eroded and
you're going to see kids victimized and
it's a slippery slope but we're slipping
right down it
now we're being told that five-year-olds
not only have
perhaps the right to engage in a sexual
relationship they actually have the
right to totally change their sexual
biochemistry they have the right to take
cross-sex hormones
they have the right to mutilate their
bodies and their genitals
that's what we're being told because
well they know deep down
that they're sexual creatures and we
need to stop them from going through
puberty so that their true sexual nature
which is contrary to their bodies can
come out it's just
it's just bogus it's weird it's creepy
the left has been peddling this stuff
for 100 years
bernie sanders bernie sanders peddled
all this kind of weird child sexuality
the kids need to explore their sexuality
he peddled this in essays in the vermont
freeman for for years in the 1960s
it's nothing new but it is wrong
and what a lot of this derives out of is
ours now social refusal to say that
anything is right or anything is wrong
intrinsically so everything has to be
about consent hey if
two consenting people want to do x y and
z they're they're totally free to do
that and i have no right to infringe on
that who's to say what's good or bad or
right or wrong as long as people consent
but then so when when you apply that to
to an adult with say transgenderism
if an adult
consents to call himself sally and put
on a dress that's his right and i have
no right to infringe that well
then then you are granting the
possibility that the man could in some
deep sense become a woman and if that's
the case then certainly you should start
that before puberty
certainly you should do that before the
secondary sex characteristics of a man
set in
that'll make it a whole lot worse if
those secondary sex characteristics set
in if transgenderism is true
the child is not consenting to puberty
that's the argument for putting the kids
on puberty blockers
and there is some kind of logic to that
if you believe that consent is the
be-all and end-all and exclusive
criterion for determining whether an
action is good or bad but it's not
we can know beyond consent whether
whether this creepy professor says that
the child is consenting to a sexual
relationship with an adult or not
maybe the child is is going up to bars
and he's sneaking past the bouncer or
she's sneaking past the bouncer and
going up to adults and saying hey toots
let's get out of here even so the child
whatever you want to call that consent
pre-consent
sort of quasi-pseudo-consent it doesn't
matter it's still
wrong it's just
intrinsically wrong and we can say that
okay we can have the confidence to say
no that's wrong and you get punished and
i don't care if you're consenting to it
you don't get to do it period
you're seeing this push all throughout
the country at georgetown
there there's a panel that's taking
place this month on abolishing the sex
offender registry
there's a panel it's a georgetown
defenders presents a panel on abolishing
the sex offender registry moderated by
professor abby smith
virtual event april 21st i guess it's
habit good happening in a couple of days
rsvp here
i looked up this professor abby smith i
thought maybe it's going to be a
professor who says no we should
definitely not abolish the sex offender
registry it's really good to know when
you've got child molesters in your
neighborhood we need to protect people
no this is a professor who has serious
problems with the sex offender registry
who wants to keep more and more people
off of the sex offender registry because
it's not fair to them it's not for those
poor people if you are
this is the professor's argument in
certain articles that i've read by the
professor
if someone finds himself on the sex
offender registry
that's going to really really harm his
life
he's going to have a harder time in
society he's going to have a harder time
holding a job he's going to have a
harder time fitting into a neighborhood
that's true
that's true
because he is a rapist or a child
molester that's why
it's not because of the awful society
and the unfair stigma around child
rapists it's because he committed that
act and the society wants to protect
itself from those people
yes
that individual is stigmatized
rightly so
by the way maybe that individual has
gone through a lot of therapy has paid
his debt to society has reformed has
totally turned his life around maybe i
wish him the best i hope he does that i
hope he's repented and goes to heaven
someday
but we in society still have the right
and the obligation frankly to protect
ourselves from the real likelihood that
that person could reoffend
i have one and a half kids i got one kid
out into the world i got another kid on
the way
i
demand to know
if there are sexual predators
anywhere near my kids
i just demand it that's my right it's
it's not even because i hate the
individuals who have committed these
crimes i hate them and i want to pun i
just we just need to protect ourselves
okay
and what the left has done here
is has so taken the side of criminals
to the total neglect of victims they
that left us so
bought into the idea of
indoctrinating little kids in weird
sexual ideologies and normalizing all
sorts of sexual disorders
and frankly cultivating those disorders
in children
in grooming the kids let's call it what
it is
that
they are neglecting the safety
of the kids that's what they're doing
you see
this point on the will this point on
desire on consent i know it's a little
abstract i know it's a little pie in the
sky here's here's
an example that i think can drive it
home and it actually comes from peta
peta tweeted out the other day animals
don't want to be eaten
and they just they did that thing that
libs do now which is just they repeat
the same sentence five or six times he
said animals don't want to be eaten
animals don't want to be eaten animals
don't and i saw this
and i thought well
animals don't want
they just don't want
they don't have a
rational will so yeah no they don't want
and peta responded to me
peta said
other animals are thinking feeling
beings who have wants and needs just
like you
you should want to be a kind person and
make the world a better place
so there are even from those first two
words they say other animals like you're
just an animal michael you human beings
you're just animals just like the
cheetah
just like the insect you're you're just
and you all have wants and needs just
like each other and that's not true
and i i chalk it up to ignorance from
peta but it's not true i chalk it up to
the extreme degradation of our
understanding of the world today but
it's just not true
the misunderstanding comes from a
misunderstanding of the human will and
so a heroin addict wants to shoot up
heroin
right because it feels good but a heroin
addict also doesn't want to shoot up
heroin
at a higher level the heroin addict
wants to quit heroin because the heroin
addict knows that heroin is bad for him
this when saint paul says the things
that i want to do i don't do and the
things that i don't want to do i do he's
describing the conflict between his two
wills
the two wills are the lower will which
we call the appetite
and the higher will which is the
rational will and traditionally
understood the rational will mediates
between the lower will the appetite and
the divine will
so
to bring that back down to earth here
we have a moral conscience we can know
certain things that are good and bad and
right and wrong and true and false and
so even when our loins and our on our
stomachs and our lower
animalistic desires tell us
go
eat the
eat the tenth taco drink the tenth drink
sleep with that woman who isn't your
wife go
whatever your appetite is telling you to
do your higher will says nope don't do
that that's wrong you're gonna you're
gonna
have a stomachache you're gonna have a
headache tomorrow you're gonna be in
real big trouble with your wife don't do
that even though part of you desires to
do that animals don't have that higher
will
so when animals see the food they just
go and eat it and they're going to go
eat it until they get sick
they're just going to eat eat eat
animals don't go courting the animals
don't have much of a sense of monogamy
or fidelity they generally just ship
whatever's out there animals
pursue their instincts and their
appetites this is why we don't put
animals on trial
when an if an animal goes and bites a
human being we might kill that animal we
might put that animal down
but we don't put that animal down
because of justice or to get revenge we
don't put that animal down because we're
even angry with the animal we put the
animal down to protect human beings what
we for sure don't do is charge the
animal with a crime and put the animal
on trial and have the animal defend
itself we don't accuse the animal of
committing an immoral act because the
animal doesn't have any moral conscience
that wouldn't make any sense
we are stewards of animals we we want to
be good stewards of all of creation but
not because the animals want it not
because the animals will it
we do that because god wills it and we
have a moral conscience so we can
understand these really basic things
in when it comes to parents the job of a
parent
is not to just give in to every little
child's disordered desire or will it's
not to say eat as many cookies as you
want oh of course it's your will i have
no right to infringe upon your no we say
no enough cookies get your hand out of
the cookie jar kid when a child when a
little boy says i i think i'm a girl
because my pervert teacher in
kindergarten told me i am
that it's not the job of the parent to
say well if that's your will if that's
your desire then i if that's your true
no the parent says no you're not
you're not i'm your parent and you're in
my care and it is my responsibility to
teach you the difference between true
and false and right and wrong and good
and bad
but these people because we've lost any
ability to make those moral distinctions
and morality in 2022 pretty much is just
if it feels good do it
it's turned us all into animals it's
turned our civilization into a much more
animalistic bestial society because of
that
we just boil it down to this incoherent
conversation about consent
speaking of consent consent is back in
the news for a completely different
reason not for the animals not for the
groomers
it's because of colin kaepernick that's
because if i
uh every two or three months
this guy is back in the news if i never
heard the name colin kaepernick again it
would be too soon this
perfectly mediocre professional
quarterback who's made a big spectacle
of himself and many many millions of
dollars he's whining again that he
doesn't get to play in the nfl
colin kaepernick
six years now is it since he made a big
spectacle of himself and said that
america's evil and disrespected the flag
and was booted from the nfl
and then made a lot more money
selling hatred of america through
sneakers than he ever would have made in
the nfl
colin kaepernick is back
begging begging to be let back into the
nfl
are you willing to be do what carmelo
anthony did if an opportunity presented
itself today and they said
we want to bring you in as the backup
would you take that yeah you'll take
that
if the opportunity i know i have to find
my way back in okay so
yeah if i have to come in as a backup
that's fine
but that's not where i'm that's not
where i'm staying and when i prove
that i'm a starter
i want to be able to step on the field
as such
i just need that opportunity to walk
through the door
he just wants that opportunity and he's
willing to even go through some hardship
for that he knows look he knows it's
really valuable for a person to be able
to play in the nfl and he knows he's
been out of it for a little while and so
he's gonna he'll he'll work as he'll do
a little bit of grunt work he'll be the
backup quarterback and then he's gonna
work his way up because he needs to get
back he just wants so deeply his desire
his will is to get back into the nfl
this from colin kaepernick the same man
who what a year or two ago said that
playing for the nfl is like working as a
slave on a plantation in the antebellum
south
what they don't want you to understand
is what's being established
is a power dynamic
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact
come on boy
look at that shape there look at this
mr fiber i got your bid 30.
30 to you 100. so next we're coming up
best one we got
500
600.
look at this here
come on who wants this
[Music]
so
there we go there are the shackles
well colin you're free
you're free colin you were previously
enslaved by the nfl
you had that awful slavery of being
really rich and famous and getting to do
the thing that you trained your whole
life to do
and now you're free from that
you're free and you get to be a clown
you're afraid to you're liberated into
clowndom you're the guy he looks like a
clown he talks like a clown
he is a clown
that's what he does now please no let me
go back into slavery oh you don't really
think it's slavery you just you're very
confused he's a very confused man
and actually
though he is not aware of this this does
speak to our misunderstanding of
liberation
the way we understand liberation today
is that you don't have any obligations
you are not bound by any limits
whatsoever be they political
cultural or even natural so you're not
even bound by the limits of your own sex
you get to just do whatever you want
whenever you want to do it colin
kaepernick wants to go out there and
make a big clown of himself and
disrespect america and the flag and the
fans and he wants and
there's not going to be any consequences
for that right
no because by the way sporting events
have always had a connection to
patriotism
going back to ancient greece
so no now the consequence is he's out
but no i'm i don't i no no please can i
have the slavery again no you don't i'm
sorry colin there's actually you will
find far more freedom
in
limits
the heroin addict breaks all of the
chains breaks all of the limits he can
do whatever he wants whenever he wants
to do it except he can't and he's just a
slave to sin
then he's just a slave
to vice
speaking of live performances
speaking of
things that some people may or may not
find entertaining such as football
and speaking of airplanes actually
getting to our first story there's a
video that i have to get to it's from
easter sunday on an airplane at 30 000
feet
a group of
christian
singers and a guitarist got up in the
middle of an airplane and started
playing modern worship music
i love the idea of this i really love
this in theory in practice
not not the greatest music it's a little
hokey
it's not not exactly box mass and b
minor you know not gr if it were
gregorian chant we'd be somewhere but i
don't can't say i love the
musical stylings here and if i were
sitting on the airplane i'd probably say
you know but just sit down and pray a
rosary and
don't we don't need to but i do like the
idea of a public acknowledgement of
easter and ilhan omar was really upset
about this ilhan omar tweeted out she
said
i think my family and i should have a
prayer session next time i'm on a plane
how do you think it will end
well muslims play on airplanes all the
time
probably not in the middle of the aisle
that would be a little strange but it
would be strange because america is a
christian country and so that would be
unusual to have muslim prayers say
during ramadan on an airplane certainly
i mean it's easter it's easter sunday
just like if i were in a muslim country
if i were in saudi arabia and i got up
and started playing christian music that
would probably be weird and probably be
frowned upon
because they're different things
and what the point that the libs are
making here is
christianity should have no special
place in america this is a totally
secular country get by the way they
would never make any
problem about a muslim getting up and
praying on an airplane they're only
doing it because they don't like
christianity
but that's that's not really the
american tradition america has viewed
itself for the vast majority of its
history as a christian country they used
to light up the big buildings in new
york and chicago it with crosses on
easter sunday they used to wreck there
used to be religious christian
proclamations from the white house from
because
we're a country with standards with
norms with a view of itself that has
that that's entire understanding of what
it even means to be a country to hold
truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal with certain
unalienable rights comes from
christianity
and we have a right to those standards
and we have a right to those norms and
we have a right to that traditional way
of life and we have a right even to do
certain things at 30 000 feet notably at
the very least to breathe the free air
as of yesterday i'm michael knowles as
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael noel show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor in chief and co-host of
morningwire on today's episode a federal
judge strikes down the airline mass
mandate the latest from ukraine and
crime is on the rise in la's wealthier
neighborhoods
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire